the America bashes were added again for
the Fourth of July the Socialist loving
Folks at Ben Jerry's scooping up some
anti-American propaganda with his social
media post quote the U.S was founded on
Stolen indigenous land this July 4th
let's commit to returning it the attacks
on America didn't stop there Squad
congresswoman Cory Bush sang quote the
Declaration of Independence was written
by enslavers and didn't recognize black
people as human today is a great day to
demand reparations now
okay I want to start with Ben and
Jerry's now they have factories I'll
start with you Greg on a land where
Native Americans like the abenakis live
uh in South Burlington Vermont should
they give that land back if they're so
willing to make sure that uh you know if
we steal land from indigenous people we
should give it back put their money
where their mouth is that's what I said
you know that's funny the entire world
is based on Conquest yes right you know
uh stolen land stolen Freedom it wasn't
called that it was just called Conquest
so good luck solving that Injustice
because Douglas Murray pointed that
pointed this out it's a brilliant point
it's the only the countries that people
are trying to get into
uh that are targeted for reparations uh
the the places that people are leaving
are just as bad but nobody wants
reparations from them these are places
that still have slavery right that still
take people's freedom but I think that
Ben Jerry's has even the score uh in
terms of against at least against white
people uh by making a product that
elevates cholesterol and heart disease
risks increases body weight blood sugar
diabetes I mean it's not giving a joy
though yeah yeah but it's not like
giving a diseased blanket but over time
this kills people and also I mean the
other thing too is if they really did
care about blacks they probably wouldn't
be making that product because they also
have high high a high elevation of uh
Diabetes Type 2 diabetes that's right
and obesity so I mean I mean how much
joy are you actually bringing to people
again it's not a diseased blanket but
over time
good point thank you all right Dana do
you think so we'll be right no it's
Dana's turn do you think that the day
will ever come when these American
hating companies realize that you don't
bite the hand that feeds you I'll uh
Target Bud Light
um it's almost as if Ben and Jerry's is
a bit
um
protected from all of this because
they've done they've done this for years
it's not even that surprising and in
fact it's like get a new stick like it
would be amazing and you know it would
be news if they said America is a great
country that would that would be like
worthy of conversation this didn't
surprise me they're just trying to be
provocative and it's a company that has
dealt with this for a while however
recently you have seen that conservative
backlash can actually have an impact on
corporate bottom lines yes and so I do
think there are many other companies
that aren't like Ben and Jerry's who are
saying you know what do we really have
to comment on every cultural issue out
there Maybe not maybe we can just take a
back seat and you know celebrate the
country that we're in participate in
trying to make it better one of the ways
to do that is by having great products
at good prices and hiring good people
and treating them well
you why do we worry about China Joey
when we've got American corporations who
literally hate American they're gladly
sharing an anti-American propaganda you
know who has great ice cream Blue Bell
you should go out and buy all the Blue
Bell Ice Cream you can buy and if you
can't find that maybe get Mayfield's uh
Chick-fil-A's got great ice cream too
when McDonald's ice cream machine is
working that's also good ice cream my
mama said if you gotta Church it up so
much you've got to come up with a crazy
name and put 15 different flavors in it
just to taste vanilla maybe it ain't
that good to begin with uh and so I'm
sorry I don't remember what you asked
but I just I don't even understand that
uh listen it is a capitalist Market you
have the opportunity for choice in this
country like no other place in the world
you can choose the ice cream you eat so
make good choices and maybe don't
support Ben and Jerry's or maybe do I
don't really care I care as much about
which ice cream you eat as I do what Ben
or Jerry have to say about things that
are important that they are very not uh
they're not very educated on yeah
that want the land where Mount Rushmore
is they took it from other tribes right
before it was taken from them they have
the absolute least standing for that
area other than that the government that
they call us corrupts promised it to
them and as far as I know all of those
folks are dead now so I don't really
care all right Jessica wrapping up
this is the thing that they do it's not
surprising everyone who eats Ben and
Jerry's who knows about this has said
that they don't care most people don't
know about this story I think and it
wouldn't really affect them but this is
also what the first amendment is all
about we're we had this conversation
around Colin Kaepernick taking the knee
and there were tons of veterans
organizations that said we support his
right to do this we go overseas and we
shed blood to make sure that you have
the rights at home to say whatever you
want about your country your government
and whatever it is and you know if Ben
and Jerry's has made it through you know
lots of statements like this their
support for the BDS movement which I
find completely appalling
um it's not going to change who's you
know taking Chubby Hubby homes and that
wasn't about an actual husband it was
just the flavor that I ended up picking
I wonder Brian Kilmeade I want you to do
me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming on your way
on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now